in the acting profession when we say
he's an actor's actor that means he's
the tough well Joe Mantell is an actor's
actor and this year Joe has been
nominated for his performance in Marty
and here he is to hand the award for
Best Motion Picture story mr. Jonathan
representing Pricewaterhouse in New York
mr. Ward Ogden I have the envelope
please is this for the best motion
picture story in Hollywood love me or
leave me Daniel
it's just goes to show what talent hard
work perseverance Doris Day and James
Cagney can do for a writer
you've heard about performers who can
read names out of a phone book and make
it sound pretty exciting well in Italy
there's an actress who can read the
numbers and make you cry a talented lady
who was a nominee for a gold statue for
her performance in the Rose Tattoo on
film from Rome Miss Anna manana we have
some stages in Rome two is one is the
venerable Medici in the Capitol it's
very beautiful it's one of our favorite
stages of course some of us have other
favorites smaller stages they are
friendly and looks nice around the house
but that is only if one liked it I'm to
say who is the winner for the best
screenplay but the paper says only cut
to Harley what is one to do one is to
open the envelope miss mañana the winner
in New York
Marty paddy Chayefsky
I'm just very proud right now thank you
very much